it's so good to see us good to see you
yeah sonica I'm gonna use that your last
name it should be seen I thought exotica
oh I'm gonna keep that yeah I'm gonna
keep that but happy belated birthday
thank you very much I'm going to take a
drink now go for it
keep going so that I may speak okay I
was so looking forward to this movie to
see how you were gonna bring this
character to life yeah and you can dance
you're easily the most you know the
smartest person on earth so I had to
work on it for a couple of weeks yeah
he's a genius you're a genius - well
there's genius in the world I'll give
you that and sometimes I get out of its
way but I wanted to know because just
recently you had a beard you have a
beautiful stache in this movie a
morphing all over the place yeah you
don't have anything now what
shapeshifter I prefer being rail-thin
and I really liked my beard it depends
on the load it really depends on the
mode I did I dug it people thought I had
answers yeah do you miss this you can
breathe back Oh it'll happen again for
sure for sure yeah now my kids are
really excited about this don't think
it's laziness but you actually have to
work a beard it's harder you really do
it's harder yeah you gotta keep it
trimmed and beautiful and oiled shampoo
stuff yeah man guys with beards turn in
movie theaters and ghosts
have you tried something something
Moroccan oil and stuff like that they
give you tips hey there's a whole
culture there's a whole cup I don't know
about it I mean I've never grown a beard
before so really no no no but my kids
are really excited about this film
because we have a hedgehog at home you
do yeah you're so sweet they are this
her first pet so what was your first pet
my first pet
I had a mouse okay I had a mouse I named
it Mighty Mouse and and because it used
to bend the bars of the cage and get out
and run around the house I couldn't keep
it in a cage it would figure out a way
to leverage the cage apart and get out
and it drove my mother crazy I would
hear her shrieking across
house oh my god it was wonderful yeah
Mighty Mouse I guess yeah and you know
what I was just watching Bruce Almighty
on the plane oh yes and I love that
movie and it's kind of roundish because
this movie kind has a metaphor of sonic
trying to live on everything off the
bucket list right
would you ever work with Jennifer again
you guys had such an amazing chemistry
of course yeah her she's wonderful yes
sir sir quite a good spirit
what good spear in the world I like her
a lot as does the world and they should
yeah yes on your bucket list my bucket
list gee I I would like to explode into
a ball of light that's one thing you
know until then I just I just want to be
I just want to be a tree full of mangoes
I like that those are sweet and they're
the gift of the gods
you know theirs is the sweetest fruit
you can have and and it's I have a mango
tree in my yard and in May the ground is
just covered in these beautiful red
mangoes and I walk out on the lawn and I
pick it up and I open it and I eat it
and it just to me it says the universe
is abundant it's always trying to give
you gifts you know so and the tree
itself is kind of like the trunk it's
big and thick and there's this all these
offshoots that are super thick and
there's like 10 or 20 of them and I
think of the thing is just this whole
ecosystem in one tree you know it's just
the the one that is the many and that's
how I feel about people you know we're
the one that is the many you know so
symbolically I I dig mangoes
I dig mangoes - yeah